[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  are you sure  privilege PR i ve i DG privilege well  dammit  yes what yeah  killing it definitely oh I definitely  know how to smell this definitely not a  spell definitely now this one I  definitely know the EF does death no I  am ii i te ly definitely yes  [Music]  diarrhea cha-cha-cha d IA h r rh e a8  yes  [Music]  all right yes yep  I don't know what there is never had it  in my life embarrassment EMP a r r e a s  NS m DN t embarrassment misspelled i FM  s PE o l misspelled they call me  spellcheck that's the English language  is dumb I was a Spelling Bee champion in  elementary school I knew as a bad  speller going into it so I'm not  surprised but why do I need to be a good  speller when I have autocorrect  it's gonna change it anyway you know  that's what dictionaries are for  anyone's language is a dump